- So according to the
Biden administration,
the war in Afghanistan is over.
But what legally allowed
that war to happen
in the first place, and
could it happen again?
Only Congress has the
power to declare war.
It's right there in Article
I of the Constitution.
So how is it that presidents
basically seem to have
unilateral ability to declare
war whenever they want?
In this particular case
we're talking about
the authorization for use
of military force or AUMF.
The 2001 AUMF allowed the president
to go to war in Afghanistan,
and there were also AUMFs in 1991 and 2002
that allowed the president
to go to war in Iraq.
Those are still on the books,
which leads many to say that perhaps now
we should remove them
since those wars are over
and we don't want presidents
extending those AUMFs to
go to war in other places.
This is part of a longstanding battle
between Congress and the
president over who can declare
and continue to go to war.
It's absolutely not a settled
constitutional question,
but the ending of the war in Afghanistan
has raised these questions once again.
So, perhaps this time maybe
something will be done about it.